hello everyone and welcome to one of my
favorite games ever played in chess
uh altogether uh it's a game from the
1895 famous hastings tournament between
uh former world church champion wilhelm
steinitz former being as he lost his uh
clash to alaska
a year ago maybe not a full year but uh
it was in 1894 and this tournament here
is in 1895 and he faces
uh german uh journalist chess master and
a member of the german nobility
kurt kurt von bardileben and we've
already covered this game but we've
covered it uh when i
only started the channel so it's a very
old video if you want to check it out
and compare it to this one
i will put a link in the description
below it will be the first thing you're
going to see
but i decided to redo it at 60 frames
per second and add some more
depth to it and some stories and also to
invite you guys
to check out a nice article about this
game uh as
it's very very deeply uh well
researched uh but i will get get to that
so uh
let's just check it out as it's uh it's
quite the game and then we're gonna
discuss
what uh what really happened what we
thought happened uh in the
the first time i made the video and a
lot of interesting stuff
regarding this uh this game so let's
check it out chinese with the white
pieces
opens with e4 and although in some
sources it's
it says that this is the first game that
was played in this tournament uh
rather in round one but in fact it was
played in round 10.
uh so e5 uh with knight f3 knight to c6
and
bishop to c4 italian game is on the
board we have bishop to c5
uh the joko piano and now amazingly even
though this game was played in 1894
in 1895 the evans gambit was not played
here but rather c3
uh schneider was uh was a big fan of
this line so the main line of the joko
piano knight f6 and now
d4 and even though everywhere in uh
like chess literature or like really
every anywhere
uh this game is called the battle of
hastings but i still stick to my
name that i uh i've given it in the
previous video
that is the the bravest rook in chess
history and you will see why
so e captures on the e4 we have c
captures on d4 and
bishop to b for check so there was a
this was a very very
uh often played line in those days
knight to c3
and now d5 knight captures an e4 uh
leads to the famous greco attack and if
any of you are new to chess i will show
the greco attack as it's something i've
learned
uh when i started learning about chess
so here you basically you sacrifice a
pawn
you castle and then you allow uh black
to capture this knight and if your
opponent doesn't know uh
uh a lot of theory or theory in general
he might go for something like
characters captures and captures attack
the rook and to this you will go queen
to b3
the greco attack has many lines but this
is one of the
more famous ones uh you will sacrifice
your rook and then go bishop characters
on f7 with
check king goes to f8 or e7 doesn't
really matter because your next move is
the same bishop to g5
now the queen is under attack defended
by the knight so the queen has nowhere
to go you have to block with the knight
and now uh we uh or rather uh there is a
game where knight captures and d4 was
played uh i mentioned this in my video
where the
asthma boy played the simultaneous
exhibition game against uh
mikhail chigorin uh where chigorin had
played a blindfold game and he missed
queen the a3 check and then he really
struggled because without this move you
don't really have a good move now but
later the little boy explained the
situation to him
now uh here knight to e7 can be played
and then just rook to e1 and
the game is over next the movie you're
just going to capture this and that's
uh that's it for black so black in this
game uh from bar 11
i decided to avoid this line and he
played d5 today it is known that knight
captures
is the best way to uh to
uh uh how do you put it to
refute the greco attack but uh it wasn't
a lot of theory wasn't known in those
days so basically if you want to refute
it
after castling don't capture this with
the knight but rather capture with the
bishop and only then play d5 don't touch
the c3 pawn just d5 the game continues
and you will have a very nice game with
black
uh so even in in databases uh like uh
after the white tried playing the greco
attack after knight captures uh
then bishop captures and d5 uh black won
more games
than white in the database and there are
a lot of games in the database
so here d5 immediately without going for
this capture
but this allows steiner some very nice
play he captures on the e5 we have
knight captures and
now he castles and here was a good uh
well or rather a great opportunity for
bardoliven
uh to castle the safety he could capture
the knight here
captures and castle the safety however
he played bishop to e6
added another defender to the knight
here but
this is where his problems begin we have
bishop to g5 by steinitz going after the
queen
bishop to e7 blocking this attack
and now steinis realizes that uh well
battle evan's king is still in the
center of the board and
a nice capture fest is in order in the
center of the board
so he trades off everything with
captures captures captures captures and
of course
characters and characters and now uh all
of this has been done
uh rook to e1 and with this move
steinitz makes sure that
battle evan's king is stuck in the
center because if you castle you just
lose uh
you just lose the knight here so uh
there's not much you can do here
a queen to e2 is coming which will add
more pressure so f6 making sure you can
castle artificially maybe
bring the rook into the game and now
queen to e2
uh threatening checkmate now so queen to
d7
defending and then now comes rook 8 to
c1 i remember when i
uh first read about this game in an old
book i don't remember which book it was
uh it was said in the book like today's
modern masters would go rook to d1
like instantly but steinitz had uh had a
different idea he played rook to c1 and
yes rook to d1 is the
uh the the move the engines recommend
here not rook to c1
but if stannis played the best move
recommended by the engine we would not
have this most amazing game
uh and here c6 was played uh there is
also another game that chinese played a
year later where his opponent tried to
defending with rook to f8
uh and then steinitz achieved an even
greater victory but we're gonna
show that a bit later so here is c6 and
c6 comes with the idea okay
you have a rook on the c file i want to
completely you know
deny this rook's existence i play c6 i
also
cover the d5 square you're not playing
d5 so i'm good here next move i'm gonna
play king of seven bring the rook into
the game
and that's it i'm super happy however uh
this only makes it uh that much easier
for steinitz to create this masterpiece
so feel free to pause the video here and
make this
brilliant move tiniest plate here while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations and finding this
beautiful pawn sacrifice and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's d5 yes that's a lot of announcing
for a pawn push but
what a pawn push it is because he just
laughs in black's face he says yes this
move
didn't really do anything uh you're
gonna capture and give me the c file
either way and i played the d5 either
way so the the two reasons why you
played c6 are basically non-existent
uh so you you capture here otherwise you
go king to f7 and then you allow d
captures here uh queen captures and then
you allow queen to c for
check and then you pick up the c6 pawn
so you will lose material if you
if you do something like this so trying
to keep uh the material balance intact
we have c
captures on the e5 and now knight to d4
now this is beautiful
stein it's not only achieves all of this
activity for his rooks and queen but
also
grabs the d4 outpost for his knight and
now also the knight is coming to e6 and
that's uh
that's a whole lot uh for the price of
only one pawn
we have king to f7 now preparing to
bring the rook into the game and knight
e6
and here if the rook comes to c7 uh
there's just not much uh
yeah you can look for here with black so
you have to prevent this the problem
with preventing it with knight to c6
is following knight to c5 now if queen
moves you eliminate the b7 pawn
and if you try to keep everything intact
queen c8 uh you also want to kind of
want to keep an eye on the e6 square
then comes queen h5 check and now after
g6 is just queen captures on d5
and black's entire position just falls
apart king g7
96 check is coming and whatever you go
you're either getting checkmated or you
will suffer severe material loss
for example if you go here then it's uh
well not much you can look for here
and if you go here you're just going uh
well under the mask of the queen and
then just anything wins knight g5
check you're gonna go king g7 queen f7
check you're gonna go here and now again
96 and
the same ideas apply black will not
survive this attack
so after knight to e6 uh here black
played rook
h to c8 saying okay you're not bringing
your rook to c7 and i've developed my
rook to the nice open c file
you have nothing here but steinitz
definitely had something he played queen
to g4
now threatening uh well not only queen
captures on g7 but rather knight here
with
check which would pose a lot of problems
for black and black said
all right i can actually defend the
queen with king 28 so i can play g6
prevent this queen captures on g7
and now we we still play uh but
knight to g5 with check and now if
you're not careful you're gonna lose the
queen so you have to defend the queen uh
so king e8 defending the queen
but now once again feel free to pause
the video and win this game for white
and uh prove to everyone why i'm calling
this game
the way i'm calling it
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
bravest rook in chess history and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
rook capture sunny seven and this is
such an amazing move
uh because you really have to figure out
what happens uh after
everything i mean of course uh you can't
really
do whatever you want uh if you capture
with the queen then you no longer have
defense of the rook and c8 so the queen
can never uh
move away from this diagonal so queen
captures is just captures captures and
captures with check
the knight covers the f7 square you're
gonna have to block and it's just a
knight against no pieces it's completely
winning for white
so instead after rook captures on e7 we
might discuss
what happens after queen captures an e7
and this is the thing you really have to
calculate
the point sorry not after queen captures
after king captures
and this is where the fun really starts
here i remember when
i saw this the first time in in in books
i saw okay there's queen before but how
do you
how do you work everything out and this
is how you work everything out so queen
to b4 with check and now
there are a lot of options but none of
them really work for example if you go
king to d8 uh it's just
queen to f8 check this is covered by the
rook so you have to block with the queen
knights the f7 check and now there's
nothing king d7 queen to d6
is checkmate on the other hand after
this queen to be for check you might go
uh queen to d6 blocking this but now
comes queen captures on b7 with check
queen d7 blocking and now rook to e1
with
check king to d8 and now or rather you
could go king to d6 uh also a
possibility but
the white's move is the same knight f7
check king to c5 or you can capture and
give up the queen so king c5 and now
you're gonna go queen captures on d7 so
losing that
and also if you go king to d8 like we've
said uh also not much better you're just
going to play knight to f7 check and
there's nothing you can do here
this is covered by the rook the the king
has nowhere to go so you'd have to
capture it in queen characters here
again you're going to lose this game of
course so what happens here after rook
captures on e7
queen captures is inaugural king
captures he's an ogo so here
king to f8 bardoliven starts running
away with his king but now comes
rook to f7 check and again it seems like
black might be able to capture this uh
and then just
after knight captures let's say deliver
checkmate with rook captures on c1
however it doesn't work because after
captures white doesn't go for the queen
but ryder first
grabs both of the rooks and then i just
uh trades down into the same end game
we can show it if you've forgotten uh
there's nowhere for you to go
for example you can block with the queen
captures captures and now just
move the knight again you have a
completely winning end game
so after rook to f7 check uh black says
okay
there's uh nothing for you to do uh
going back with the king
ends in checkmate instantly so that's
again not a possibility so here
king the g8 but now uh this rook
continues to boldly go where no rook has
gone before and
rook the g7 check happily continue uh
continues
to check the black king and again you
cannot move the queen
otherwise rook captures is always
winning like we mentioned the queen
cannot move from this diagonal
so or rather if king captures uh you uh
you've moved the king from the back rank
and now the queen gets captured with
checks so black is in and not in time to
deliver checkmate
so again now the queen cannot capture
the king cannot capture
the the only move is uh king back so uh
king the h8 uh if you go here then just
knight captures with with the same idea
king captures queen captures
so king to h8 and now rook captures on
h7
with check and this is only move 25
and this is where the story of this game
basically starts because
the way i've read it uh in old books was
that
uh when uh when kurt von bottle even saw
what was happening here and he realized
what
was actually going to happen uh that uh
steinitz is going to not only win this
game but most likely get like
the biggest possible applause that was
ever gotten in chess
you know maybe uh maybe i don't know
frank james marshall got a
uh an applause that big for his american
beauty but uh
all in all uh uh it was said that uh
kurt von bartolin left the table was
without resigning uh he's trolled out uh
and uh that a coin was turned
that if you do this then you pull uh
pull up a phone bottle even
and that you just allow uh the time to
run out so you don't have to resign the
game
uh and this is what i thought actually
happened for a very long time but i
decided to
now as now there's a lot more
content online available so i've
searched the chess history.com website
and i found a very nice article by
edward winter
and here i will link to it in the
description below because it's very
extensive i would
very much recommend for you to read it
but there is another site to this story
with a lot of uh
cited sources because he the they
they have on their website uh uh like uh
whole what happened by soltis there's
also uh party in casparo's book in my
great predecessors about what happened
in this game and they all supported this
story by soltus uh but uh there are also
a lot of uh uh a lot of quotes a lot of
sources about
uh this not actually happening that uh
badly what bart laban
actually wanted to achieve uh was that
um he wanted to avoid
his opponent getting the applause but
not for the reason uh they
they stated uh but rather uh for the
reason that
uh batter laban did not want the
applause to annoy the other players
because this was decided already prior
to the tournament by the
tournament committee uh that uh you know
applause uh
shall no longer be tolerated even though
it was a common practice uh but
that it uh annoyed the chess masters and
it was uh it was uh
very long uh for some reason like they
didn't just uh applause and then that
was it
they applaud it for like a minute or i
don't know uh
a very long time as they say but like i
said i don't want to spoil too much as
a lot of research went into this uh uh
well article so uh it will be like the
second link in the description below do
check it out
you will enjoy it now i will show you
what actually happened so steinis had to
wait for
the time to uh on the clock to run out
uh and he had
he had this time to work out everything
that can happen and he worked out a
forced checkmate in 10 moves so we're
gonna show it now
as it is quite the beauty so what would
happen here is that
the queen still cannot capture because
of the same captures and captures so you
would have to go back with the king king
g8 but now the rook follows the king
king to g7
rook to g7 check and the rook still
cannot be captured
and the thing is if king to f8 now then
knights the h7 check
forces the king to go back if king the
e8 then just queen captures his
checkmate
so you'd have to capture it and now
queen captures queen is with check so
black
is no longer in time to deliver
checkmate and he will just pick up all
the material and win
so what you will have to do after this
check is
go back to h8 but then comes the
the mating sequence uh steinitz had in
mind queen to h for
check king captures and g7 queen to h7
check king to f8 queen to h8 check
king to e7 queen to g7 check now and now
of course the if king to d6 uh just
queen captures an f6 with
check so king has to go back king to e8
queen to g8 to check now
king to e7 and queen to f7 check and now
after king 28
we reach the exi the exact same position
that we've had
uh if uh king the d8 play was uh if king
today was played in that position
although all that time ago uh but uh
as it didn't the rook had to do all of
this journey and be
extremely brave so now you could achieve
queen to f8 to check
uh there is no move for the black king
so queen has to block and now
knight f7 check king to d7 and queen to
d6
with checkmate so this is what would
happen if uh kurt von bartoliman had
continued the game
there would be an applause of course
even though i guess they uh
they asked the viewers not to give
applause uh as it
will be very distracting i mean uh you
could imagine in today's setting that
you know if
i don't know carlson wins the game and
the people applaud you know the other
players will will be like
come on you know we are you're messing
with our concentration don't do that
uh but in those days it was i guess
common practice so here
again i i do hope you enjoyed this game
and really do check out the article
uh by edward winter on his uh on the
website at chesshistory.com
uh there are a lot of interesting
stories regarding this
match uh or like like they also
mentioned that in the hasting chess club
where this game
was played the chairs that they used to
sit for on this game are still there and
people still use them
so that's a you know fine piece of
information and also i will show you the
standings
after at the end of this tournament
because this is a legendary tournament
it was won by harry nelson billsbury
followed by mikhail chigorin emmanuel
asker in third zigberg tarash and then
wilhelm stein so steins won fifth place
uh even though he was already a former
world champion
but as you can see kurt von bartoleben
isn't all that far behind
so after steining's their shifters and
body laben and some very famous names
uh after bard 11. so barbara lemon was
actually a really really strong player
and he was uh he was uh not leading the
tournament but he was doing extremely
well like he was i think second uh
behind the
uh sorry uh he was second behind uh uh
tara
or chigorin i think chigorinha chigorin
was leading he was second and then after
this game he had a terrible streak and
he like didn't really do all that well
for the rest of the tournament
whereas for steinitz i found this
incredible
uh also story on the chess history
website so do check it out full of
incredible stories
and i will read it as it's just super
super amazing so it's
from the uh article some chess
celebrities whom i have met by
rhoda a bowels on pages 23 27 of the
yearbook of
chess 1907 by e a mitchell
so it's called steinitz in tears and
it's really
really awesome as it talks about what
happened prior to this game
so it says among my earliest chess
recollections i recall a pathetic scene
at hastings during the 1895 congress i
had just arrived from london
and on the stairs leading to the hall of
play i met poor steinitz who upon seeing
me burst into tears
and said oh marambaos what shall i do i
have just lost my game to lasker
and that is my fourth successive loss i
shall never win again even my own pupil
young pillsbury has beaten me and i
cannot sleep at night
for three nights i have tossed and
tumbled uh but sleep is denied me
i am utterly broken down and he wept i
felt a big lump in my throat
but i tried to cheer him and back begged
him to come home
and to go to bed even if he could not
sleep he thanked me but went away with a
sad heart
promising however to take my advice uh i
was
up bad times sorry i don't know this
word
i was up bad times the the next morning
okay weird and when he entered the hall
i was waiting with a buttonhole
uh which i pinned in his coat telling
him that i had come to turn his luck and
should expect him to win that day the
change in his look was startling
uh from a haggard expression he
developed an eager look of desire for
his opponent
this proved to be bart laban against
whom he worked up one of the most
beautiful games
of the age and
sorry about that one of the most
beautiful games of the age
and on the 25th move uh i think it was
he beckoned me to
his table and said thank you you have
indeed changed my luck and i declare
mate in 10 moves so and not only did he
show this to
viewers but also to uh madame bowels
uh and he indeed won the brilliancy
prize for it
so as it stated here and to an uh
admiring crowd he demonstrated the mate
and afterwards received the price of the
congress for it which is the
the brilliancy prize uh the first
brilliant surprise is there were more of
them
as being the most brilliant game played
poor steinitz he always regretted that i
had not come
four days earlier one of his
idiosyncrasies was a strong objection to
his opponent's
striking matches during the play he
declared that each strike broke the
throne of his
thoughts and in consequence lost him
much time in reforming his
plans but okay this uh later part is not
in much
regard to this game but just wanted to
share that and this is only a fraction
of the goodies that you
will have available on this link so do
check it out second link in the
description below
uh really a lot of stuff regarding the
history of this match
so uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it
and my uh well sort of an improved
version as we've already covered this
game but
i just wanted to show it again in 60
frames per second and a bit more
uh history behind it so i do hope you
enjoyed that as well uh i would like to
thank uh
evan sterling uh david compton i find
you robert kejmar and carl dieder for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage
of the morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do check out our chess manga if you
still haven't will be the third link in
the description below
see you soon